if your parents are financially helping
you you need to change your tone and
tender how you interact with your
parents I don't think there's anything
bad about getting support from your
parents what I'm trying to keep you all
away from is entitlement because that
destroys the soul you know why so many
people are unhappy they expect everyone
to do everything for them they expect
the government to do it for them their
parents to do it for them their company
to do it for them their boss to do it
for them their boyfriend to do
appointment their girlfriend like get
off that I'm sure you all know who Gary
is by now an amazing amazing human
um this is 30 minutes of really just an
open q a really nothing is off the table
uh Gary super own honest and open about
everything so we're just gonna go
raising the hand function and zoom and
buy the queue and so if we want to start
raising our hands I'm just going to
start calling on people and let's get
into it before Andrew jumps in um I just
really want to encourage everyone like
honestly ask me genuinely anything I
want to bring you tons of value here
there's nothing scary you know at the
end of the day like I have so much
empathy for like starting your career
and trying to figure it out and honestly
I think some of you probably already
felt this like Vayner is different and
so you're probably getting a lot of
advice from Friends older siblings
parents that is actually like counter
advice right like the world has been
trained to be a little too robotic you
know less human and I think you know the
vulnerabilities and the nuances and the
intricacies are our strength and so you
know feel free to ask me anything I
really want to bring Clarity and I'm
super pumped for this I've been looking
forward to this all day and I'm just
really flattered that you wanted to be
here you know there's a lot of different
places you could have been
um and uh and so I I hope it's going
super well maybe like maybe if I show of
heads or thumbs like hooked up
experience is going well so far I want
to keep it going so
um yeah let's rock and roll let's get to
as many as possible
um what's up Gary I just wanted to say
hey I don't know if you remember I was
that Polaroid uh intern Kid last year
Snapchat photo
um later ended up being my LinkedIn post
so you know real roundabout way for
social media but um you know I've
started posting every day just random
content that really would just fall into
two buckets health and or lifestyle
um and I'm kind of starting to see you
know a couple thousand
and I was just wondering you know where
now would be the best spot to like
Leverage the position on it did you say
you're starting to see a couple and then
I got paused for a second what did you
say you're starting to see what starting
to get a couple thousand views was just
curious where to leverage uh the spot
I'm in got it I think nowhere
what I mean by that is I think it's pre
you know I think it might be a hair
premature to leverage meaning
it it depends on how you're defining
leverage I mean are you talking about
monetization are you talking about
opportunity like double click into
leverage for me
um I would say just more or less either
narrowing an audience to become more a
niche or deciding you know what uh We've
started to get into a good routine maybe
we should you know generally map out a
plan to start monetizing it definitely
not monetizing it you know I think way
too early right just a couple like those
like I think people
rush into that too much the longer you
can hold your breath of monetization the
better and as far as niching I think the
reverse I think you need to try more
genres because you don't know yet more
cohort more genres not less
gotcha thanks awesome
awesome let's go on to Mia hi um I'm one
of the residents in the London office
and one of the things that we've been
talking about over here is um they've
mentioned like lattice roles and
particularly I'm one of the media
residents and we
um I've got media people that are like
media Creative Media strategy media CP
is there anything in particular that you
think would be some great skills to
focus on more interdisciplinary anything
that you think like the agency as a
whole is sort of moving towards trying
to like blur the lines between
disciplines
it's a big agenda for me to blur the
lines which is why In Pockets like
London and other places where testing
and learning and touching and trying I I
want all of you to be as good at like
think about the concept of this why
wouldn't if you have the interest and
the capacity why wouldn't you want to be
good at everything right and so we're
playing with a lot of things be it like
we we used to be more blurred then we
got very siled to figure out the value
of that now we're trying to get more
blurred in certain areas you know
performance creative feels very real
that a media person could also do the
Creative
there's a lot of media people who don't
realize how good their math skills are
too and vice versa so we're strategy and
creative by Nature can blur so there's a
we're contemplating I think to answer a
question directly that brings value to
everybody I think this is a game of
self-awareness all of you need to
get to a place that looks like the
following
stop trying to be something for somebody
else
stop trying to be something that you've
made an ideology out of and start
getting to know yourself on what you're
good at and what you like
maybe you want to be in media because
your mom was a math professor and she
thinks it's the radish but if you
[__] hate it even though you're
naturally talented because your mom was
a math professor like that's only going
to play out for so long
right and so there's a million scenarios
like that so I think um what I'd like
you to focus on all of you is
feeling safe
with not judging yourself not beating
yourself up for what you're not and
start getting excited about what you are
amazing thank you so much
of course hi Carrie how are you
oh I'm Hadley I'm a creative resident
for
um I have one question what was the most
vulnerable point of your career and had
you move past that as a tougher person
a really good question vulnerable not
challenging vulnerable
or I want to make sure I capture you
know because vulnerability comes from a
place of like either you are sharing
you know what you're feeling or you're
in a curious spot
like you're not and then you were able
to get through it is it the latter yeah
the ladder
I would say that it was a mental hurdle
of knowing that I had to leave my dad
for me to ever be happy
you know I'd spent 22 to 34 building
this huge company for my dad by the way
this is about to make you feel really
good if you have Financial stress I
literally worked
literally actually no [__] 8 A.M to
10 P.M Monday through Saturday and 12 to
5 Sunday
for 11 straight years with like 38
vacation days over 11 years
build a business from 3 million a year
to 75 million a year on my back and got
paid 50 to 70 000 a year the entire time
because if any of you are immigrants
that's immigrant family business life if
I worked at Vayner I'd be making like
500 000 a year when I was 29 you know
like so
um
when I knew that I was starting to form
resentment towards my dad because of how
big of a business I built for him and
how little I was getting that was
challenging for me because I was blindly
in love with my parents and had a
mission and was doing this unique thing
and it felt great for a very long time
until it didn't
and having to like deal with that was
very challenging one starting to have
negative feelings towards my dad wasn't
nice to
you know I was like [__] I have no money
like and I'm like really good and like
I've got these I gotta buy the Jets I
have like eight dollars you know like
that was very challenging for me and you
know just to give you context
vaynermedia only started 14 years ago
and I had so little money that the
company started in another company's
conference room because we couldn't
afford rent really crazy stuff so that
was the most loadable spot
um hi guys thanks so much for taking the
time
um my question is a little bit um I
guess kind of similar to Hadley's but
um at your point in your career
obviously you've had event success with
a bunch of different companies in a
bunch of different Industries
um and you continue to spearhead a lot
of these industries and kind of new
Concepts that you move in what motivates
you I mean every day you wake up what
what keeps you from just dropping
everything moving to can and just never
working a day in your life again like
what what is
what is the motivation
um well the motivation is when you just
said pick up move to can and never work
again
you for normal people who aren't in love
with their [__] the way I am you
basically just said to me like Gary what
stops you from taking a boulder
off a mountain and smashing your head
with it and dying like to me like the
thought of like moving to CAD and like
like can's nice for a week but the
thought of like waking up in the French
Riviera
365 days a year waking up and going to
the market and getting fresh and this is
like something that I think is nice for
a week getting fresh fruits and
vegetables and like by day 19 like I'm
dead by day three I'm Nancy and it's
because I genuinely like what I do and
so I think what motivates me is I I
really like really like it bro like I
think people don't believe people like
I'll give you an example I hated school
so much that I was a dnf student even
though I probably have the intellect to
have not been a dnf student but like
when people don't believe people that
love what they do for a living I get it
because
actually here's something fun by show
virtual hands how many people really
liked the process of school like liked
it like the pro like right like I don't
like I just see a lot of hands going out
like I don't understand what the [__]
you're talking how but to me I
understand that because when I'm out
here pumping unlimited content of like
do what you love it's the [__] like
I'm so happy this second bro and I have
9 000 headaches right now there's like
[__] going through my mind right now
that's going on behind the scenes of the
2000 employees and the 80 businesses I
have and all it's and I'm a public
figure and people [__] on me and all
that like there's but I [__] love it
so the answer is it's my [__] DNA
it's what I love to do like literally
think about the think about this some of
you may know this about me my favorite
hobby is to go garage sailing which is
in essence like a version of playing
business like it's it's like it's who I
am it's what I love so it makes it
really easy for me brother which is why
I really want people to hear me in this
meeting like maybe marketing isn't the
right thing like like you're at the age
all of you right now where like if you
feel in your soul
that you're a chef you need to [__]
try like I'm not in the business to like
make you guys all leave Vayner I'd
prefer you not but like if it you're at
the age where it gets a lot harder to
follow your dream at 35s than it does at
22.
right now you're willing to live with
four people in a [__] and eat [__]
food because you're a [__] kid like
I'm willing to do it and I'm old like
you're definitely willing to do it so
you know for me the motivation is super
simple it's I don't even it's how I
breathe
like the dream for me is not to get the
money to do the thing the dream to me is
to do the work
has it sorry just a small follow-up has
it always been like that or did one day
you wake up and you realize that you
love me so it's always been like that
for me and I got very fortunate and I
know that's not the way it is for
everyone but I stumbled into what I
liked it was called lemonade stands and
washing people's cars and shoveling snow
and working my dad's Liquor Store at 14
and stocking shelves like I got there
which is why I always challenge all of
you notice what I just did in the slack
like that that's like a weird thing for
a CEO to do I'm like hey why did I do
that I did that because I'm hoping even
one group of five people decide to get
on a zoom that don't know each other
which leads to them maybe getting a
drink that leads to them like starting
an improv club together like like you
know like I want people to explore like
I'm just petrified that all of you have
locked in
and you haven't tasted every option or
more scary to me that you're suppressing
what's actually in your stomach to
appease your parents or your logical
self so for me it's always been their
brother but I promise you the second
like you open your mind to thinking your
favorite hobby or your favorite thing
can be a business or a viable way that
you put a roof over your head your life
changes and by the way one of my
favorite things about Vayner is you're
learning such insane skills here that
map to anything and everything if you
decide to ever take that jump at 25 29
36 41 52 and let me give you some real
[__] Wisdom I'm 47 right if all of
you you're gonna I hope you remember
this in 25 years do you know what the
craziest [__] about being 47 is I
straight up sitting here with all of you
right now think we're friends like I
think I literally think like we're the
same right now right this second I'm
like yo let's go out after this like
like I think we're the same when you
when you feel that when you get older
that will blow you away because when I
was 22 and started working full time at
my dad's liquor store my cousin was 30.
I thought he was a [__] hundred years
old like I'm sitting here talking to you
being like yo we're the same if a 47
year old said to me that we were to save
at 21 I would have laughed my [__] it
it's like I'm like a thousand to you but
in my stomach I feel like we need to go
play video games and like [__] I
don't know like what are you saying like
it's it that is the best part of life
that nobody tells you like it doesn't
change as much as you think
of course
all right we'll keep moving along when
next up is Eaton oh
hello Gary
um thank you sorry this has been very
humanizing it was a very poignant point
about your dad it's just been something
I think about kind of having somebody
who teaches everything for 20 odd years
and then you enter a world and know
anything about it's a
someone I've been grappling with it was
just nice to not hear
um
my question
um I've noticed uh around there's a lot
of Comedy people coming in there's a lot
of comedians who work at Vayner uh I
have a comedy background for a couple
years now where do you see the value in
people with that skill set in that world
there's obviously a huge intersect with
I've been very focused on this I think
improv comedy skill set is
an advantage to the future of marketing
and I'm recruiting very heavily against
it
you know ironically when I started doing
public speaking like I've gotten some
crazy compliments from Top A-list
comedians about how I do public speaking
and it's and when it started happening I
was like wait a minute this makes so
much sense
I never I never did a public speech
until I was like 33
and like I just listened to Richard
Pryor and Chris Rock like like I
listened to stand up in my car instead
of Music in high school that's how much
I liked it and so you know I just think
it's about ideas and being comfort and
especially stand-up comedians aren't
scared to bomb you can't get good at it
until you get comfortable with bombing
and I think that's how I think about
creative too many people are scared for
the creative not to work I'm only good
because I'm not scared and so yeah I'm
very excited about us tapping into it
and we're gonna do more and more
look full disclosure we're going to
start having some company meetings
around like creators are getting too
left field and just making [__] for the
sake of making it like it's got to have
a little bit of a business lens but I
but I think but I still want to keep
tapping into heavy creativity and I
think that comedy DNA is real and we're
going to keep investing in it thank you
very much of course hi Gary I'm Julia
I'm a PCS resident I just want to say
thank you so much I appreciate you a lot
uh as you can say I'm not American I'm
Brazilian
um seeing your videos was one of the
reasons why I quitted my job resetting
my career my family said you're crazy
you're too old for that but I was like
I'm not and I'm happier than ever so
first of all thank you so so much for it
and my question is more about the
Imposter syndrome I know that sounds for
real you're like a figure like a public
figure so how do you deal with that
every day even like on work meetings
everything I know it's a safe space but
at the same time we all get it so how do
you deal with that well first I think we
have to have a conversation of what
imposter syndrome is imposter syndrome
is the slang term for insecurity like
first we gotta do that like we've made
an acute term that feels kind of like
all right and I actually think that's a
good thing like I don't say that like I
think insecurity is a power I think
everyone's hiding from it I think you
just need to look it in the face like
everyone in this call should be insecure
in certain meetings you're four seconds
into the game
you're a human being of course
what I would say is
if you realize that you were in a talk
about a safe space I expect very little
from all of you except to try be good
people and try to learn I don't need you
to get crazy in the meeting and come up
with the most profound consumer Insight
in the history of time let me give you
something that you can carry with you
forever the other thing that makes
people insecure is you want your bosses
to like you or think you're good here's
the good news as long as you're fully
yourself and you have good intent if you
find a place where your bosses don't
feel that you can go somewhere else it
happens within Vayner as great as Vayner
is and it's great
there's Pockets where it's not great
because an executive right now has
decided they don't like me and this
company anymore and they're not going to
be as nice the next month until we
figure it out and try to fix it you know
like it's life somebody who's the best
just had bad news in their personal life
and for the next three months they're
not going to be the same selves in
meetings and they might be a little
snippy with you not because you're bad
but because they found out that their
mom has terminal cancer and they haven't
been ready to share it with anybody
they're crushed life's complicated you
know but but what I can say is stop
being insecure because it's not that
serious this is just a job like what I
promise you if all of you get fired
eight jobs in a row your life is still
going to be epic we've done a lot of
things societally wrong one of them is
we're just taking way too many things
way too serious and so you know I just
really hope that you realize that of
course you can have some insecure
moments
every day at work you're still learning
some of you haven't even grasped the
thing you're supposed to be learning yet
I'd be insecure as [__] is that if I'm
like I [__] don't understand what
this math is or I'm not really sure what
the [__] Gary's saying with all these
acronyms they're like like I get it
but your good news you're nine seconds
in nobody here is judging you to master
anything we want to see the intent the
effort the humanity and the capacity to
continue to build do you know what I
mean like this is why I hate school
everyone's insecure because you think
you need to get an A there's no [__]
a in here thank you on that note Gary
can you uh can you please deposit a bold
as [__] bat into my openc account if I
send you my uh openc wallet Patrick I
have no idea why I'm saying yes to this
but the answer is yes let's [__] go
dude that's inappropriate like I'm
cheering like that but dude what do you
mean that's inappropriate I've cursed
like 86 times in the first 23 minutes of
this meeting
okay next up Paige awesome
um Hard One to follow but hi Gary I'm
Paige I'm a Creator resident I'm working
on
and I feel like you get asked like a
million questions or at least you're
always answering questions like on your
Instagram and one of my favorite things
that you talk about is like you should
not have [__] figured out in your 20s
it's okay to be overwhelmed to go chase
that dream to go traveling to go do
whatever the hell you want to do
so I'm curious like was actually I don't
want all of you to hear this I apologize
Paige yeah no you're good actually all
that [__] I talk especially if you're
standing on your own two feet
financially
where people get [__] up on like yeah
Gary's told me to travel the world and
this is that like you know like if your
mom and dad are paying for it like
that's different if you're if you're
doing like a job for three months saving
and then going with your homie and like
rugging it out that's [__] epic you
earned it where people get caught is I
don't think there's anything bad about
getting support from your parents but
I'm gonna give you a really good piece
of advice if your parents are
financially helping you
you need to change your tone and ten or
how you interact with your parents like
respect that that's where people get
[__] up because what I'm trying to
keep you all away from is entitlement
because that destroys a soul you know
why so many people are unhappy they
expect everyone to do everything for
them they expect the government to do it
for them their parents to do it for them
their company to do it for them their
boss to do it for them their boyfriend
to do appointment their girlfriend like
get off that it will the quickest way I
can promise to make all of you happy is
to stand on your own two feet and be
accountable and expect from yourself you
will get so much happier I promise
anyway go ahead was there ever a time I
was just gonna say was there ever a time
when you you know traveled or succeeded
at something or failed at something and
it like changed your mindset or your
trajectory in some way that still sticks
with you today I needed to be
accountable and I realized that my
inability to be candorous with the
people I loved the most was a huge flaw
you know but I've learned to find my
balance with kind Candor and I think it
makes me a better CEO it makes me a
better dad makes me a better friend like
you know when I think about me I don't
really take any credit I think it's all
about my parents it's their DNA they
parented me when I think highly of
myself I don't think of it as like ego I
think of it as like co-signing how epic
my parents are and I've always I've
always thought highly of myself I have
but it was kind of fun to discover a
Kryptonite and Candor was that for me
and so if that resonates for some of you
I get it it's hard to like
tell the truth to someone you love if
you think they're gonna hurt their
feelings but I promise you the quicker
you can get comfortable with
disappointing someone you love in the
micro you'll get away from macro
problems so if anyone's got my DNA in
here start practicing because I really
wish someone told me at 22 to do the
same
[Music]
foreign